did you see that leaders of the satanic
temple aren't just outraged with texas's
strict new abortion lord they say it's
also a matter of religion did you see
this
no okay so
leaders of the satanic temple consistent
with all our tenets that call for bodily
autonomy and acting in accordance with
the best scientific evidence the satanic
temple based in salem religiously
objects to many of the restrictions that
state have enacted that interfere with
abortion access the religious groups
website says temple officials are also
taking matters into their own hands
lucian greaves uh satanic temple's
co-founder and spokesperson said the
temple has sent a letter to the u.s food
and drug administration citing religious
freedom to seek the ability to provide
its members with abortion
pharmaceuticals as part of and i quote
it's satanic abortion ritual within the
first 24 weeks of pregnancy
i thought first off that this was like
some you get pregnant
are we normal are we normalizing
satanism
it's already normal apparently they've
got half a million uh subscribing
members in uh great which is more subs
than me and you've got
i'm sure someone will find a way to
slander my name for saying that hey
maybe maybe being a satanist isn't that
great of a thing
maybe
you know maybe satanism isn't a
a a good route to go down
well they are managing i want religious
freedom here so to qualify for abortion
this is the thing right i think
okay yeah so i thought that what they
did was it was some like really really
evil thing where people would get
pregnant and then they'd like celebrate
killing the baby it turns out it's not
that it turns out it's even it's kind of
weirder than that
what they do
they deliver
abortion pharmaceuticals
so they they actually deliver it so that
you go through the satanic temple you
get clearance from a medical
professional yeah and then
it goes to the american college of
obstetricians and gynecologists
uh and then this is a quote from that
guy who said so it wouldn't really be
any different to if they just went to a
practitioner and got it directly from
them it's just we would be the ones
distributing it so like
they they do multiple things not only do
you go to them to worship satan but you
can also
have you have your abortion but see at
what point does being a satanist really
mean being a satanist you know a lot of
times people will be like
hey you know
you worship the devil and then
maybe a satanist back to them would be
like no actually
we focus on the main tenets of and they
wouldn't even say the word satan they
would
it has to do with choice and all this
stuff when all of a sudden it's evolving
into another religion in an of itself
you know at a certain point regardless
of whether they believe one thing or
another
it is a pretty nice virtue signal for
the satanist
you know whatever the satanist
group is
to announce that they are
providing uh
abortions or abortions depends on what
side of the aisle you're on if you're if
you're trying to get right if you're
trying to get the conservatives to be
all well yeah but you'll never get the
conservatives when you're when your
group is called a satanist but
you know there's i'm sure there's a lot
of people on board with the satanism
satanists now and i cannot believe this
is our conversation thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that then
press here for the full unedited episode
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace